derrière la crise sanitaire la crise
économique l'un des secteurs impactés
le sport ça championnats majeurs de foot
à avoir tout arrêté pendant la pandémie
la france craint de se retrouver
décrochés à face à ses voisins européens
le championnat d'allemagne a par exemple
reprend lui le 16 mai le ballon rond
craint pour son économie en france
illustration avec le racing club de lens
dans le pas de calais le reportage signé
pierre pissavy yvernault avec jordi
demory ici résonne d'habitude l'une des
plus belles ambiances de l'hexagone
depuis presque deux mois maintenant le
stade bollaert delelis résidence du
racing club de lens sonne creux comme
toutes les autres enceintes sportives du
pays plus de football donc plus de
spectateurs pour les clubs
professionnels il a fallu s'adapter
un arrêt brutal de la compétition qui
représente forcément un manque à gagner
c'est ce que nous précise arnaud
pouilles directeur général du racing
club de lens
on s'est posé avec notre propriétaire
pour anticiper les choses de manière
c'était que 1 comme on avait beaucoup
vendu en terme de
d'argent et de recettes l'an dernier on
a quatre de l'an dernier ça nous a
permis de mobiliser des créances sur les
transferts qu'on avait et deuxièmement
nos propriétaires anticipé aussi en
s'engageant sur une augmentation de
capital donc ça nous permet de passer ce
moment très compliqué qui et sociétales
sociales mais qui aussi économique un
niveau avec la moindre des perturbations
possible c'est aussi l'avis de la
gaillette centre d'entraînement du club
qui est actuellement bouleversé la
plupart de la centaine d'employés
travaillent aujourd'hui à domicile et
les jeunes du centre de formation ont
été renvoyés chez eux pour faire face à
la crise le club extrêmement populaires
dans la région a pu compter sur ses
fidèles supporters
ils sont nombreux pendant cette période
compliquée à faire preuve de solidarité
on a voulu mettre en place des ventes
aux enchères donc au quotidien faire des
enchères sont différents maillots tenait
donc par les clubs des personnes lambda
également des joueurs qu'on a récupéré
on a pu récupérer donc une somme globale
d'environ 33 mille euros
compass directement en dons à l'institut
pasteur est légalement aux hôpitaux de
france
il ya également une action monte donc
avec le club également pour pouvoir
effectuer donc d'aider sur vous pour
pour les soignants on a pu faire plus de
55000 sur blues qui se rendent
directement donné au centre hospitalier
comme toute entreprise les clubs de
football sont donc eux aussi touchés par
la crise à lens une perte de 4 millions
d'euros est estimé
mais alors que le club fait toujours
face à l'épidémie une bonne nouvelle est
venue égayer l'avenir des sang et or
après plus de cinq ans dans
l'antichambre de l'élite du football
français
le racing club de lens retrouvera la
ligue la saison prochaine